كل من دلعت نيران الاحتجاجات حاول ماكرون
وحكومته اطفائها بلغه الصمت والتجاهل غير
ان السنه اللهب هذه المره تغلبت على خطط
ليصبح الاحتجاج فعلا متصلا بالزمن والمكان
والهدف اسقاط قانون المعاشات
الشارع الفرنسي غاضب جدا من الرئيس
فماكرون احرق الجسور مع الحلفاء والشركاء
المحتملين على طاوله التفاوض وحشد اغلبيه
الراي العام الفرنسي ضده
ورغم المقابله التلفزيونيه التي اجراها
وكسر من خلالها صمته شبه التام ازاء اصلاح
قانون المعاشات ودفاعه عن التشريع الجديد
باعتباره ضروره اقتصاديه الا ان السخطه
اصبح حاله مرشحه للاستمرار
فمهمه مواصله حكم فرنسا اضحت اصعب امام
ماكرون بدون اغلبيه داخل الجمعيه الوطنيه
اذ ان 19 من النواب الجمهوريين ايد اقتراح
حجب الثقه عنه
الاهم من هذا ان الرئيس الفرنسي فقد ثقه
الراي العام الفرنسي فمعدلات شعبيه ماكرون
تراجعت لمدونه 30%
المحتجون الغاضبون يتهمون رئيسهم بالغطرسه
في التعامل ويعتبرون ان ثمت حاجه لوضع
نهايه لهذا الامر ايمانويل ماكرون ربما
اصبح بطه عرجاء تقول وكاله بلومب
الامريكيه ملمحه بذلك الى انه قد يكون
عاجزا عن الاستمرار في ممارسه الحكم فيما
دعت صحيفه الى بدء جمهوريه سادسه تكون اقل
سلطويه فصوره فرنسا بصفتها مقصدا للاعمال
تضررت جراء الاحداث الجاريه ما ايقظ مخاوف
ماضيه حول بلد غير مستقر اقتصاديا وسياسيا
ايضا بلال البجدين العربيه